hey guys Dimitri from the score eSports
now if there's one siege player whose
name is constantly being thrown around
in conversations regarding best in the
world
it's Kanto Raquette II or does it
successful plant goes down from G to
Kantos there wanna play from Kanto to
take out two and Shepard with no yokai
after making a name for himself on ents
this finish Fragger joined G to where he
amassed a pro league title a major win
and ultimately a world championship now
whether he's fragging out on Ashe or
holding it down with Ella there is no
denying that Kanto is an absolute animal
so sit back relax and enjoy as we count
down the top ten times that contour
Ketty went ham in professional Rainbow
six siege kicking off our list is cantos
beautiful Jaeger clutch against space
station gaming from the 2019 six
Invitational with three attackers
collapsing on him in garage canto had no
choice but to sit Waits and plan out his
next move if your SSD bet especially not
that kids are getting a very tight angle
onto chala and down he goes close for a
second gets it at third
excellent doesn't play from cancer a
Kenny and all of SSG er Feld what
monsters performance by Kia doing
exactly what you expect coming in at
number nine is cantos trophy room hold
against teen font in the pro league
season three semi finals finding himself
on the losing side of a 2v4 canto
punctuates to window picks with a lovely
little peekaboo on the lurking havana
and oh he's gonna come back and then
it's to avoid that he sees Branca any
doubts if it doesn't finish him off and
now Astro pushes in different side his
kids are gonna be able to get on they
will that is essentially a double he
sees map and what a kill from canto
pizza walks into trophy and says no you
cannot have my bomb site please go away
and he manages to tear apart every
single attacker that attempts to
challenge him Wow taking the eight spot
on our list is the ash clinic canto put
on against his eventual teammates from
Penta sports after kicking things off
with a casual wallbang canto eases
himself into a skillful peak before
gifting of volley of precisely delivered
shots into the domes of pentas to
on-site defenders this right here is why
Ashe had her ACOG taken away thanks
Kanto influenced a play off of her
attacker oh that's right next to you the
wall but you just can't look just before
that they have till right after Pat
showed off the hatchet for the time
can't adjust showcasing why is playing
prone
when you see plays like this against the
best team in the world right now the
title holders there's nothing else to
say really in this spot
[Music]
coming in at number seven is the second
time that cantos ella went ham on chalet
at the year - season 3 finals with the
clock ticking down canto finds himself
in a 1v3 but even he couldn't anticipate
after picking up a quick vertical kill
canto leverages a gutsy railing hop into
a double kill that leaves the enemy
Blackbeard sprinting for the diffusor
wishing he'd never equipped that heavy a
shield to begin with
who is he playing inside a trophy just
by that Doyle and Emma Bob can't tell a
nice kill on the psycho that is crucial
but BZD gets Wilkie and still with
Benari down it's gonna be up to canto
and Bootsy to hold this on and boots
he's gonna get one before being
pressured by kamikaze he gets down it's
all up to catch so he sees Giulio and
he'll take him down so now it's a to be
one essentially kamikaze sees pzd can't
know are you kidding me it's just
kamikaze lap and now canto is gonna wait
out the time they can't do it in time
can tell kid sir of Kenny is again he's
the player who had stepped up and filled
the void that was on and they needed
somebody to just get the kills make the
plays and establish the advantages
topping off the back end of our list is
that time canto turned ashes r4c into a
scalpel in the pro league season 8
semi-finals with four bodies to drop and
only one teammate alive to help him
canto staves off two charging defenders
before humiliating the enemy anchor in
his own home proving once and for all
that you can't run or hide from ashes a
cog when Kanto is wielding it to
advantage of course here for fanatic but
the head shots been found lusty will get
dropped flashbang thrown in though
the top rift up here in the bathroom the
riccati low on health bases
she finally gonna get dropped does he
find the head in the back of my store
damage job chapter rotates the needle a
thundering roar this is absolutely
insane Cantor a Kenny showing why is the
carry rocket coming in at the midpoint
of our list is cantos calculated clutch
against team empire during season nine
of pro league with zero help three
attackers on his scent and the diffusers
sitting halfway across the map things
weren't looking good for Kanto but
Empire forgot the golden rule of
clutching that with a lot of patience
and just a little bit of BR foresee
anything is possible for a Fragger as
deadly as Kanto roquette e cuts down
Bobby and leaving just can't tell
Raquette II say goodbye to Scyther no
far away they are nobody is really in
position right now to be able to take
Canton down he's gonna be exposed for
another 4 3 2 1 seconds and then well
he's got some mono he takes out joystick
and all the pings right now on to
Shepard low on HP Shepard might be blind
oh what a great shot oh who bought
through scotch on banana he'll get
Shepard say bye bye and g2 will move on
to match point
all because a wonderful one on three
from Canton taking the fourth spot on
our list is probably the dankest Castle
clutch you've ever seen that's right
we're talking about castle with all
three attackers on site and the thin get
to make his way back into the Oregon
basement Kanto is tasked with pulling
off one of the toughest retakes in the
game post plans by himself as Castle the
drop happens Joker's notes just to the
stay put
canto picks off one he's got two more to
go free fires around here is gonna move
in as well there's gonna be one smokin
each Kindle is going on out as well
Cindy feeds around the corner and the
penny cut the kill can Joe walk it away
with ten health down stithi it's all up
to a clutch here one ball from either of
these players we'll take the other out
we either have a trade or we have a
victor who's gonna have walked out on
top here he's had the adventure he's
prone behind the dory right now canto
ever is gonna change him around he's
gonna grab the block canto grab that
three on one clutch he's gonna secure
this victory for EM they had everything
in their favor and every one of them
Pete every single one over Pete and
unfortunately fourth millennium that is
not how you want to end this series
taking the third spot on our list is yet
another instance where cantos Ella
provided a visceral reminder as to how
badly this operator needed to be nerfed
into the ground with a scorpion in his
hands and little to no recoil standing
in his way
canto is able to eviscerate three
members of black dragons in the year two
season three grand finals before camping
out a truly tilt inducing fourth to help
close out the first round of the series
see psycho he's got that top west side
control and he's gonna continue to try
and clear out these rumors but it's just
continuing to stall cancer Kenny the
first kill of this series the second
kill of Visser the third kill of this
series takes out Giulio and bzd before
it gets a refract from kamikaze what an
amazing Rome from cancer a Kenny he's
taken almost all of wags help down as
well he's gonna get pushed by kamikaze
is he gonna be able to get out that's a
fourth kill for Kanto Wow I feel cheated
I feel absolutely cheated as a spectator
he got all but like three hmm of every
single one of them
[Music]
taking the penultimate spot on our list
is the truly disgusting ash clutch canto
executed against faze clan in the pro
league season eight grand finals with
the diffuser sitting miles away and two
defenders camping both entrances to obj
Kanto has no choice but to engage both
at once
little did they know Kanto has no issue
killing two birds with one stone and
Yanis Bank wished leaving Kanto riccati
to deal with the three remaining members
of phase and very quickly he will reduce
it to two with Maringa and yuna then
this is a very winnable position with
that r4c in the hands of the finn i need
to grab the diffuser it's quite a ways
away and moringa prone with the shotgun
blast can't go around the corner
silencing the crowd absolutely insane
aim there from cancer a Kenny the
transfer as clean as it gets
taking the top spot on our list is the
single most jaw-dropping Kanto play of
all time The Jackal rush against phase
in the season 8 Grand Finals now in
order to understand just how dumb this
is a little setup is required phase
inhabit the single most defensible site
on bank all of their operators are alive
and they have virtually every piece of
utility at their disposal to make things
worse G to have exhausted all their
options their plans gone to [ __ ] and
they have just under a minute to make
something happen and all that really
matters is how will T to mix things up
because phase still have full utility
they might have you expended a single
gas canister while we weren't paying
attention
like I find it unlikely in fact no
moranga has all three all of the sea
fours are still in play and there's only
a minute left for g2 to delay this so
with nothing but smokes and a dream
Kanto decides to make one smoke grenades
going down and it's gonna be a drop from
G to a very aggressive play you know
Lance SC 400g ona's but answer a ketene
inside a ball will take out math and
it's just a absolute wall it took it's
three for himself though kind of four
it's all Astro now and he's far off
sight he shuts down Fabien but the
Claymore from Koga finishes things off
as Kanto drops or smokes drops and foots
next to the mirror window takes out MAV
takes out Moringa takes out yuna I
believe it was a 4k as he also took down
camera man okay guys that's our list be
sure to let us know in the comments what
other Rainbow six siege players you want
to see you get the top ten treatment be
sure to like the video subscribe to our
Channel and we'll see you next time
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]